live welcome everybody to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here and blast from the past old friend
of mine Joanne is with me here today
well I met Joanne through Ronald and
salsa we were we danced dances together
and in in this iteration of joins life
she is part of fresh gigs and is doing a
bunch of marketing and blogs for them
and wanted to interview me for her five
things Friday series and I said yeah
let's do it and let's turn it into our
YouTube hang out so you guys could learn
about what she's up to two um so join if
you want just give a quick intro what
you're all about and then into the
questions let's do it hey well thank you
for a nice intro fresh cake or a table
in Canada it's based out of Vancouver
but they're trying to break into the
toronto market so i have been charged
with helping them establish a presence
in Toronto so I am technically their
blog manager but I wear many hats so I'm
writing I'm editing I'm sourcing content
for them and it's a lot of fun they're
great companies super super cool
organization to be with so one of the
things that I came up with is for the
five things friday and that's where we
interview cool people such as yourself
who are doing things and we ask them
questions and here we go so are you
ready let's go I'm excited the first
questions is super easy one and what
when you were a kid what did you want to
be when you grow up ooh I want it to be
a a part-time baseball player and a
part-time police officer is the baseball
season is is short right so during the
seasons only baseball player and then in
the opposite of a police officer that's
when I was really young I don't know if
that's what you want as I grew older I
in my high school yearbook it says I was
gonna be a VP at a bank when they ask
you like where you're gonna be in ten
years so that's what i thought i was
gonna be I didn't you know obviously I'm
an entrepreneur now
but um that didn't really happen until I
got to university okay a part-time
police officer baseball player their
mind ero growing up with Kelly Gruber le
Gruber Kelly Gruber you know that the
blond hair third baseman for the Toronto
Blue Jays Oh Molly what's that we have a
mullet did he have a mullet I don't know
it was it was long I don't think it was
quite mullet style but but it was long
um yeah he was my hero growing up so I
know you are a big baseball fan so
that's still stayed with you yeah all
right second question what was your
first business idea and what did you do
with it my first business idea was when
I was five years old I convinced my
three-year-old little sister to draw
paintings with me and go sell them door
to door ah and we sold one to our next
door neighbor for ten cents i think uh
so that was my first sale yeah uh so i
don't know if you qualify that as a
legit business idea but that was my
first so you were an art dealer in your
early years mmhmm yeah I wasn't the
artist artist I was just representing
the talent I like it um well beyond that
there's grown-up business idea i do like
that though you were yeah i like uh so
this is interesting because i had a
whole bunch of ideas growing up but i
never thought i was going to be an
entrepreneur mostly because my
environment I didn't have entrepreneurs
in my environment parents had normal
safe jobs they always encouraged me to
wherever I wanted but it wasn't even I
had all these tendencies it wasn't
something like thought I was going to do
so I had lemonade stains I once tried to
turn raisins into grapes and sell them
realize that it goes the other way
around does that that didn't work I sold
baseball cards you know we used to do
garage sales all the time and I would
have my 12
zol selling baseball cards and kind of
make more money than my family did at
the garage sale just by selling cards
and then a bunch of kind of failed ideas
that I tried and never really took off
the the idea like the first kind of like
adult idea that ended up doing well was
as a biotech software company and I
didn't come up with the idea I met
people to people at University you've
University of Toronto who had a piece of
software and wanted to get it out there
more and I came on to help market it and
grow the business and became an owner in
the company this were the three of us
who are owners and it was helping
helping researchers find cures for
cancer and diabetes and AIDS and all
sorts of important issues that were
trying to find cures for so I was that
was like my first kind of grown-up thing
that I did that actually had success a
whole bunch of small successes and
failures before that well you're a bit
of a hustler I can tell you've got that
spirit and you know they always say that
old cliché if you first if at first you
don't succeed try try again and I find
that's a common thread with a lot of
people who are doing things for
themselves they try everything and it
runs the gamut it's never just like I'm
always going to try to be a book
salesman it's like I gave me a book
salesman a shoe salesman I'm gonna be an
art dealer you know so good
stick-to-itiveness that's what we call
it we've got people watching xenos
asking I have a very important question
for you Joanne do you believe I do and
heels that I can be a part-time baseball
player and police officer I cannot give
up on that dream Thank You Xena I
appreciate that keep hope alive um so
you said you never really thought that
you'd be an entrepreneur but what made
you finally make that decision was it
actually a choice or was it just like
you know through written in the stars
kind of thing oh this is this a good
story so I'm in my third year university
uh this is when i connect with the two
entrepreneurs and I and I join but we're
sucking at the start like not making any
money you know it I just took it on as a
challenge
this is cool why not you know I got
nothing else to do school is kind of
boring um why not yeah I'm willing to
help and I was I wasn't making any money
I was making 300 bucks a month right
like it's nothing uh you know it's like
massively below poverty line money and
then when I was coming to my fourth year
I had opportunities to work for Merrill
Lynch and McKinsey Consulting merrill
lynch & Investment Banking McKinsey big
switch youth costings consulting company
and only like a year prior that was my
dream job right like here they are pain
like 80 to a hundred thousand dollars
starting salary you know they flew me to
New York put me up in the world upper
story for the weekend promises to like
fly around the world and do deals and
it's like what I always wanted and then
coming out of that I felt like something
was missing with this company and and I
didn't want to live in regret but that
was the thing that was holding me back I
felt like I can go take this job but
what happens if this business takes off
and I'm not a part of it or you know I
didn't I didn't give it my fullest and
that helped me make the decision to
think well you know what I'm gonna give
it a year I'm gonna give this a year I'm
going to try to make my business happen
if it doesn't then I can always go back
and get the safe job that I thought I
always wanted um and at the time was as
me now it makes total sense and everyone
back and ever got a job it was you know
everything worked out fantastic yay
hooray but at the time was super scary
because all my friends one of those jobs
here's what I thought I always wanted
logically it didn't make any sense you
know like 80 to 100 k vs three hundred
dollars a month why would you ever do
that one and it was just that feeling
that I had to try it out I didn't want
to live with regret and I use that
actually as a framework for
decision-making now any kind of big
decisions that I'm scared about I try to
like fast forward to age 80 looking back
on my life am I going to regret no not
taking this action and and I'm super
grateful because you know a couple years
in I'm
up with some of my friends and their ass
asking me how do i be an entrepreneur
because i hate this job that I tell can
I go man that that should that would
have been me dying in these corporate
jobs and so yeah looking back it makes
total sense but it's hard to connect the
dots looking forward so it really enter
ship rounding you in a sense yeah I
think I think it's always been a part of
me in some way through the art dealer
and lemonade Zane's and baseball cards
and i joined junior achievement when i
was in high school and a bunch of kids
get together after school and sell towel
bunnies and you know a bunch of products
but even through that I felt like I'm
gonna be a banker you know when I
graduated high school I think I've
always had it any I just didn't have the
environment to support that I didn't
have entrepreneurs at school come and
teach and show that it's an option so I
think by taking that I mean that
opportunity that came to me with the two
people I'm not sure everybody would jump
on that um I did because I felt there
was something in me it was a colony had
to go do it so did it find me I guess
and I'm grateful because if that didn't
happen maybe I wouldn't have discovered
it at all and maybe we'll taking me
longer um and I kind of wish I
discoveries hey so yeah wouldn't be able
to have my interview with Joanne it's
kismat it was meant to be okay here's
the next question for you what habits
they think of helped make you successful
that's a great question I think I think
your environment in your habits told you
where you are and anytime you want to
make a change and break through and hit
that next level because you've changed
your environment or your habits somehow
for me what I find is and this might be
specific to me I find that I can get
easily motivated by video or a book or
an interview and I found that it was
happening randomly you know like I
happen to watch some video and I get all
excited and motivated energetic and then
and then the rest of the day I'm off
working and
super happy and putting everything into
it and then I wake up the next day and I
it's like I'm starting over again like
where was the oven from yesterday what
happened to that guy and so I didn't
acknowledge that or wasn't aware of that
for years and when I discovered that
then is it ok well how can I use that to
my advantage and now every morning I
start off with something that inspires
me that gets me trying to think bigger
that gets me to try to push outside my
comfort zone and sets me up so that's
intentional every day instead of
randomly happening because I happen to
watch some video or so my morning
routine is pretty set so every morning
I'll wake up and just write down three
things that I'm grateful for just
quickly on a notepad beside me I just
find starting your day with a little bit
of gratitude helps set me up for like
why I'm why I'm here what what if she'd
be thankful for some of them they're
deep you know like my family and you
know the team that I have and some of
them are you know I'm grateful for the
Sun and for the internet and open the
Internet I'm right hi it's at the point
where like the he can go off in the
house and the water can be shut off and
there's no food here for as long as we
have internet everything is ok but the
anthemic goes down like you don't know
what to do so I find that that really
helps me uh then I'll think about I'll
put on some music I have a set list and
I find music is a great way to kind of
get you out of your change your state
put on something that makes you come
alive what's that what do you listen um
I have a playlist I have called the
believe playlist and I put that on its a
mix of stuff some of its salsa some of
its mmm some of its like it's all over
the place there's no like one song that
helps people but I feel like any music
that makes you want to do that that's
good right like something that gets you
moving right I used to stand up desk I'm
standing right now most of the time I
like marching on the spot while I'm
working so need I need something that
has that vibe
energy and then I'll think about kind of
what my goals are for the day I remember
what I call Big Y little Y the big why
is the what am I trying to accomplish
and I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs little why is the
day-to-day things so looking at my
youtube comments as an example somebody
writing in insane having that video you
made yesterday really inspired me you
know those little things just make me
want to keep going make me want to keep
doing it and then I fall into the rest
of the day so those morning habits that
morning routine really helps get me set
up properly for the day and anytime I
find it i miss it I'm lower you know
like I missed my I missed my you know
songs in the morning or something it's
just not quite the same um and so I
think I may be like the weird one but I
feel like if you set up morning routine
that sets you up for success you'll have
more success well you know it's funny
like that every can't you just can you
just knocked off two of my questions
which is what's your product it secret
and how do you find inspiration so
that's where I was going with that I
love it deeper into both of those
appearance um yeah quickly your
productivity secret aside from you know
setting up your routine and and having
that thing that you do every day to to
keep your energy levels up what what
other secrets are there at you have i've
got a bunch one nope no cellphone and no
phone oh yeah i don't use a cell phone
uh and i don't have a phone i have a
phone number but it's I always do skype
Colleen and I didn't use a phone and
that's a that's a strange one yeah
that's a strange one but it's really
other people's agenda for your time I
hate being interrupted when I'm in the
flow on something if I'm writing my book
and yeah I mean you can your writer your
you understand here writing and then
somebody calls you even if you don't
answer it you look at who it is and God
what does that person want and you
ignore and then you try to get back into
your writing
in that it take you like half an hour to
get back into it um so that's a minor
one but no I don't do any I have no
phones no cell phone no I'm in don't let
people interrupt me um yeah that's a
weird one I chunking my time um so every
day I do something differently so
today's Thursday we're talking to
Thursday all of my public facing stuff
is on a thursday all my hangouts radio
show interview you know phone call skype
calls whatever it's always on a thursday
monday is my I'm acquiring a business
and I spend my time work on that
business there's an acquisition one day
bremen a Monday I like that I like that
I got a kid named it that's good I like
it see look at that I'm learning to of
this um tuesday is my writing a so i'm
writing the book with penguin Random
House and I have to get it done by
January so I walk the whole foods and I
right there on Tuesday when's is my
video day so I'll record videos will we
have three videos that come out a day on
the channel so it's that's 20 videos
plus that I have to record on a
Wednesday and then Thursday
public-facing day Friday is my CEO day
big picture day have something on my
team come over and we meet up so
different days for different things and
I find just like the the phone can
interrupt you and make you switch having
different tasks in different days helps
you stay in that zone so example if I
had to write and then I had a meeting
coming up be from this right like before
we got on there was like half an hour
that I had nothing to do so then I'm
like okay well let's see what Jones up
to and let's look at fresh gigs and see
you I look at somebody else's five
things and and then some people may not
be on time or late or whatever like
that's a lot of lost time and I find at
least for me that public face ain't
energetic passionate evan is different
than introverted writing let me get this
stuff done don't talk to me Evan and so
I have a hard time switching like I
couldn't write for half the day and then
be communicating and out
half the day yes oh I like having here's
my whole foods day I'm in my sweats you
know nobody bother me and I'm just
sitting out cranking out lines and then
thursday i can focus on being outgoing
energetic Evan uh that really helps me
with my productivity excellent okay um
because you do do a lot of public
speaking how do you how do you how do
you get yourself amp for that and how do
you combat your nerves with the public
speaking because you do a lot how many
engagements would you say you do a year
to do oh I've actually tried to pare it
down mostly because I've tried it I want
to stay here and be close to family and
when you have kids that changes your
schedule and priorities what I find is I
have a flaw in that I want to uh I want
to please people I hate letting people
down it's like it kills me to let people
down so I'm always on time I'm always
early for things I'm always trying to
give more value and you can see that's a
good thing but it's also the flip side
is I worry that I'm not gonna help
somebody and I were then gonna let
somebody down and so for the longest
time in speaking I would secretly hope
that somebody would cancel on me right
like you set something up like two weeks
down the line like oh yeah I'll [ __ ]
that your wine great great great and
then like day of oh my god I could refer
to do this I hope you're wearing cancels
you know I don't wanna and then it's
always fine when I minute that hasn't
happened as much I think just with more
experience that happens but yeah for
whatever reason that that need to feel
like I'm helping somebody has gotten in
the way and and held some things back at
least used to and it's just reminding
myself that hey this helps me do my big
goal and I know you know reminded myself
that I can add value that I can't help
this person and every other time that
this has happened it's always been great
it's never been a total bomb I
so I used to have to do that a lot more
just reminding myself of how I can help
people and knowing believing that I can
help people now not as big an issue i
think it's just I've done so many
interviews and speeches and
presentations that it becomes more
normal and natural but it used to be a
bigger part and I used to have this
PowerPoint file that I looked at in the
morning before I was on YouTube and got
great feedback where I would take quotes
from people who have been to my sessions
just as a reminder that like hey the
stuff that I'm doing matters and is
important and is impacting people's
lives because it's it's easy to forget
for me at least again it's you go do a
presentation you're on such a high and
then the next day wake up and again it's
gone so I create down on an ongoing
basis okay that's you know what I relate
a lot to what you just said about the
whole introversion and hoping that
somebody cancels this this actually is
is combating one of my a little bit of
social phobias like I have a really hard
time with being on camera I don't like
the way I look on camera I don't like
the way I found on camera oh so this is
also an exercise for me but I did I I
wasn't hoping that you canceled because
I knew this would be a great interview
so you're one of the very few where I'm
like okay let's do this usually am I
love it all those great comments people
are happy they love you too so this is
good um if you if you had the chance to
start your career over again would you
do anything differently that's a tough
one um you know I try to live life with
no regret we talked about regret
framework and thinking about when I'm
eating looking back I I try not to spend
too much time thinking about mistakes
and what I could have done differently
and at the end of the day I am really
happy with where I'm at right now and
really excited for for where I'm going
and so that's a collection of everything
that has happened and so if you take
away one of those bad experience I might
still end up where I am here
I think if you like transported me back
in time at some events I might change
something up you know like Oh Evan don't
do that don't say that you could have
been so much better I don't wear that
guy hey guys what's hi not what to like
even talk about speaking I'm sure
there's some speeches that obviously now
I'm a much better speaker than i was
when i first started so if you took me
back to that first speech and i had the
opportunity to make some improvements
and adjustments in like insert 2016 Evan
15 Evan jumping jumping jumping tonight
cells anyway ingesting insert 2016 Evan
into like 2000 for Evan um you know I
might I might do that but i don't i
don't like harpin and I don't wish I
made any decisions differently in the
past I don't wish I can go back and
change anything I'm i don't i think
that's part of being happy like I think
as a happy person I'm generally pretty
optimistic and I think you can't spend
too much time thinking about some people
get locked so Pat so so deeply in their
past and their mistakes that they
chained themselves out from doing
anything great ongoing and I think
recognizing that you don't have to be
who you were and that the future give me
whatever you want um not reflecting too
much on the past just I don't know makes
me happy my god I like it um here's what
ring would you like to have to know with
who don't like the most have dinner with
like somebody outside of you know family
and friends something big like you're
thinking who would you who would you
like to sit down and pick their brain
yeah just dead or aligned as I can't
let's do dead and alive Oh dead end
alive okay dad I would probably say AP
Giannini uh he's the founder of bank of
america and and is my favorite
entrepreneur made me think of bankers an
entrepreneur doesn't make sense um but
he was a big believer in the little guy
he was the guy who gave Walt Disney the
money to start his first feature length
film when everybody thought like
cartoons are never gonna go anywhere
when there's a huge earthquake in San
Francisco and all the banks kind of got
shut down because the bills were
destroyed he went to where his bank was
with a wheelbarrow full of money in like
two barrels and a plank and started
lending money to people based on a look
in their eye and a handshake to help
them build their lives because like you
need money your house just got destroyed
you got to take your money out um and
you like imagine a banker now giving you
a loan base of a look in your eye and a
handshake you know good luck with that
um so he would be you he's a pretty
unknown entrepreneur I think and bank of
america does a terrible job of
explaining i hope they're listening
anyway um yeah so he would be dead um
you know close close behind would be
Disney or jobs entrepreneurs I respect
for different reasons um alive alive
alive such an interest in one um
question this is bunch of people that I
look up to and respect uh first person
that comes with the first person that
comes to my head probably Richard
Branson uh feels like it's a cop-out
answer though I don't know I feel like
is it it candy because he is the go-to
but when you think about how diverse and
how interesting and just how creatively
brilliant he is how could you not want
you yeah I you know I think too like I
feel like a lot of the people are not
the living people are not not so out of
reach you know like if I really wanted
to I could arrange to meet Richard
Branson well then why don't you cuz I
don't really want to yeah it's it's got
another like I don't not like if he
invited
me I would say no for sure but it's not
like uh meeting somebody I don't get
it's not starstruck it's like oh my god
Richard Branson you know I don't know um
just mad Richard Branson it's more than
may I feel like that now i'm doing like
I'm going the opposite um yeah I feel
like meeting AP Giannini or Disney or
jobs it would be like you know impactful
on me not that the others won't wouldn't
be it's just it's not even close to me
in the same level I don't know am i
disrespecting living people baby you're
gonna get a phone call from Richard
Branson we listen Evan come on what's up
this is a huge honor uh yeah I guess I
just feel like it's not that out of that
far out of reach and so it's not you
know here's the thing like I rarely pine
for things uh if I want something I
don't have like these dreams that I want
to go I'll just start doing it right so
you know I wanted to build a house and
then within a year I found a piece of
property in sort of building a house um
and so that's just the way my mind works
like and I get attached to it and I got
to find it and go out and do it and so
there's nobody that I've ever really
wanted to meet um really I don't know
I'm I don't know is I'm sure if it came
I would be like I would find a way to
make it happen but people I look up to
and respect you know Richard Branson
gary vaynerchuk Eric Thomas you know
watch their YouTube videos all the time
are active engage with them but to set
up meetings and stuff with them wouldn't
I feel like it wouldn't be that
difficult maybe it's cuz it's not a big
challenge that I'm not that motivated by
I don't know okay well that nicely
rounds out my very last question for you
because you said if there's something
that you want you just you go get it so
what's next for you where do you go from
here um that's a great question my
bigger term like life ambition is to
help a billion entrepreneurs and so I am
all in on two projects one is my youtube
channel so three videos a day you know
taste a little bit more because any more
hangouts um so I'm super hardcore on
that
and then my book and so what I've
shifted towards is now thinking if you
want to have a big global impact if you
want to reach that many people it
changes the types of projects that you
get involved in work on so while I love
working one-on-one with entrepreneurs I
don't do nearly as much as I used to
because it doesn't scale as much so even
this like you want to do an interview
happy to do it happen to be a part of it
hey let's do it on my youtube channel
it's got YouTube on the brain everything
is like seeing through a YouTube filter
you asking who people I wanted to have
dinner with you know I said Gary Vee and
eric thomas who there are the youtube
channels that i watch so I love the
platform and I see a lot more coming my
my next goal with youtubers have a
million subscribers we're at a hundred
and will close at the month around 150
just passed 150,000 um so million is
like a good stretch goal to try to ronk
all right and then the book how to deal
with penguin Random House that comes out
in January I've never written the book
and I don't know if I'm gonna be a
ongoing writer if that's a one thing or
like a tons of book thing um I'm
obviously still pretty young how old am
I 30 weird 35 35 and a half hey you have
your still count I feel like once you're
past the age of 2 I don't think I feel
like they do eight and six and a half so
I feel like I can be 35 on that 35 and a
half um for all of my like longer-term
uh you know I changes so much I don't
know I can't do it I know there's that
people have like ten year goals and five
your goals and here's what want to be
for me if I see a five year goal I want
to make it happen in one like how to
make that happen in what I don't have
five year goals it's now go attack
that's maybe like a very manly answer i
don't know it's not gonna flex a muscle
but that's okay um cool well that's it
for me you've answered all my questions
well people are writing in your future
loving these questions thank you there
you go you want to see more check out
hold on what's it called again five
things friday on fresh gigs ah let's see
what else we have coming in ah something
to build an answer just most people
saying thank you thank you great
questions some days I want to ditch my
phone I want it I'm well no phone that's
how you'd like my phone on silent always
and it's annoying to people because they
try to call me and I don't hear it re
it's a good scrap my last ditches
facebook i'm on facebook for like
friends and family and my team if you
need to reach me urgently facebook is
the place to do okay instant messaging
on facebook ah zeno says you look and
sound awesome Joanne Thank You Xena got
a new fancy set you too Carol you're
gonna get a signal coming on board um
I've tried to come with a business idea
for six months how common are great
business ideas can I do whatever idea
pops up what do you think it's a
question for you some things i think
really need to UM go the way of the
dinosaur but I'm kind of like you if you
believe that you can do something if
there's a way to make it happen i think
go for it because at the end of the day
at least you know you try right it could
be the most ridiculous thing to anybody
else but if you find a way to make it
happen then who's the winner in that you
or or the people who told you that you
couldn't and i'm i'm a big fan of
somebody tell me that I can't do
something I love it when people tell me
that yeah because I'm like okay all
right you said I can't watch me watch me
I like it I'll let you gotta kiss the
muscles on that one too yeah I think you
should to think you'e Greta the things
that you don't do the things that you
wish you could do and I find that people
often have these moments of boldness
where you get all exciting you really
believe in something and then and then
you tell your friends or your family or
you put out
and like they beat you back down that's
why I said your environment and your
your habits and your rituals hold you
where you are because you know you may
have this idea that you want to break
free but everybody around is telling you
can't do it it takes a really special
person to be willing to break free of
that environment to then go out and
still chase your dreams anyways in terms
of finding an idea i'm a big believer in
just testing things out try things out
and see we'll see what makes you come
alive because often the idea that looks
the worst on paper is the one that and
you end up winning with i think about
salsa since we have that as a as a
mutual connection um you have a question
just forgot my most important question
i'm gonna ask you really quickly the
most important question okay miami even
my boss asked me to ask you in a
completely forgot all right what's the
most important question everyone is
waiting do you think that there is some
connection between salsa and in believe
and business can you make the connection
between the two you know for me I
believe I believe in people uh I I
encourage people when others don't and I
see things I often see greatness in
people where they don't see it in
themselves and the way that that most
makes sense to me is through
entrepreneurship because I have a
background entrepreneurship because I
love it I see somebody with great
communication skills or great writing
skills are great artistic skills in well
you could really be an entrepreneur when
they may not have again in their
environment have anybody telling them
that so the belief mentality works for
me most through entrepreneurship but it
definitely applies a salsa in that a lot
of people come and dealt themselves like
I can't be a great dancer you know I
don't know how to do a double turn I
can't do XYZ anywhere from helping out
students who are trying to learn and
pick up steps to then helping out our
instructors and potential instructors
get better and believe in themselves and
push them selves
it's basically seen a better future for
somebody than they see in themselves and
I think everybody ideally has people in
their lives who pushed them to be the
best version of themselves that's at the
end of the day what believe is all about
for me and so I can I apply that to any
situation that I mean I can't help but
it's me so you know if I'm if I'm doing
salsa i applied this also if I'm doing
something else i'm applying it there so
there's a there's a direct connection I
think because it's a it's a it's a
personal mantra or philosophy for me and
so if you if you find out what is the
mantra philosophy for you you're going
to bring that to everything that you do
so you know our entrepreneurship and
salsa connected kind of is believed
connected kind of it's more like what I
it's me I'm like the unifying link
because I bring me into both I bring me
and believe into entrepreneurship and
mean believe into salsa yeah I like it
and I think I've said that like nine
times I like it I like it good well we
only need five things I was telling the
salsa story about about discovering your
next business idea ah for I figured who
asked a question there mr. Angel Island
mr. Angel Island right it's a fun name
on paper I look like a terrible salsa
dancer you know I didn't grow up with
the music I don't speak Spanish I still
don't understand it I've never heard
salsa music before I you know took
classes I'm tall the item 62 63 so like
I take big steps which counts against
you when your salsa dancing learning
something as an adult versus something
I've already learned and done before
says like all of these things that would
on paper like typically is what we do
right you come up with an idea and then
you compare the pros and the cons you
write everything down there'd be no
reason for me to get into salsa dancing
none but I went to a class and I fell in
love with it and that's it I gotta do it
right right so
they're big decisions with your with
your heart and small decisions with your
head always right so if you if you've
been spending six months trying to find
a business idea mr. Angel Island just go
out and try more stuff until you find
something that makes you come alive and
I use the example of in one year once
rock climb and snowboard in salsa
dancing the rock climbing i hated
instantly I'm afraid of heights I still
said yes so right like I still said yes
to try it's a good one I'm afraid of
heights the thing is in my craw change
what was it for me it wasn't me I'm
tired of hearing rock climbing for those
of you who are fans and I'm like um uh I
did snowboarding and I fell in love with
that too became obsessed with it and I
would be I would push off meetings to go
snowboarding but that that lasted for
like one season and then and then that
was it like I went still burning every
day in the winter for one season and
then it fell off and i still liked it
and we'll go a couple times a year but
that's it salsa dancing I fell in love
with it and it's been over 10 years and
I still spend 20 plus hours a week doing
salsa stuff I be in meetings with people
meeting with another guy talking a
business over coffee and I like imagine
if I took his hand and I spun him this
way and then put it over here like I'm
making up turn about is that i blank out
for five minutes of the guy position so
like when you find that that means you
know you're on the right path like you
have to go find a way to do more of it
and that's what you'll find success I
like wasn't you maybe last question cuz
we gotta I know we gotta rush yep um
list plane to joann what would be the
big change coming in marketing for an
entrepreneur what's the big change you
see coming for entrepreneurs and
marketing oh my goodness that's an
interesting question because i've been
i've been sort of asking that of
marketers myself and what I'm finding in
in my travels is that people are very
how do i say not linear but they focus
on one aspect of their marketing and i'm
finding now that you really have
be a multi hyphenated person it's not
just so much to be a digital marker
anymore it's a digital marketer and then
you have to be a public speaker or you
have to know your social about your
social media but you have to add on your
your skills like it's not so much to
just be one thing anymore like with you
you're Evan Carmichael your help
entrepreneurs you're an author your
speaker you know you have that sort of
comma comma comma after your name and
I'm finding that more and more people
coming into a wanting to go into
freelance and doing things on their own
they really need to expand their their
toolbox it's not so much to be a
specialist anymore you have to be sort
of a multi hyphenated a person and
that's the only way I'm finding that a
lot of people are trying that success
they have to branch out it's not it's
not just your home base anymore it's
many many pockets I like the cama cama
cama cama smeet means your billionaire
to by the way recon was a billion not
there yet though on my way um you know I
would say if you look in the future of
marketing I would say one video uh you
look at who you know look at who the
kids look up to these days you look at
13 year olds and eight out of the 10
celebrities that they look up to all
YouTube stars like people you may have
never even heard of and so YouTube video
videos is the present in the future and
I would say even further live video like
what we're doing here interactive video
I think any business if you're trying to
get broader awareness on the market side
you should have a youtube channel and
should be doing video and then try to
encourage a live audience and get that
going you see periscope you see meerkat
you see snapchat there's just going to
be more whether youtube wins the game or
somebody else video and live video i
think is the game for the next couple
years I agree join thanks for the time
again for people watch our tune a little
late where can they find out more about
you you can find us at WWF Reggie a
slash
we don't have a fancy name for blog yet
but it's coming but that's where we are
we published generally on Tuesdays
Thursdays and the five things Fridays so
yours is up coming very soon and i'll
send you link and let you know when it's
when it's published i love and a round
of applause for Joanne's first google
hangout she did awesome nobody can you
know they're all clapping at home you're
all [ __ ] home to join your happen in
the chat it was great Evan thanks so
much for inviting me cool thanks Joanne
dr. st. come dance one of these days
come on I know next Wednesday all right
okay thanks John